going outside can be dangerous these
days a poisonous cloud of dust has
settled over the 20 million inhabitants
of the metropolis many fear than in the
coming weeks the smog will be the worst
it's ever been somebody get us through
our thoughts some are getting heart
attack our sorry are increasing these
volunteers hope they can make a
difference they're working with an NGO
to visit Delhi schools and teach
children how to protect themselves from
acute smog half of the Capitals children
already suffer from breathing problems
children are also learning what's making
the air so poisonous and what they can
do about it feeling like congestion and
you know in my awareness to the people
that we should not believe they're as
it's it's affecting assume we cannot go
out too many cars burning garbage and
large construction sites many factors
contribute to the smog clear action is
necessary but government bodies
literally you know they're not making up
completely so because this is an
emergency they have to take some harsh
steps also cuz they should be you know
coming up very fast otherwise we'll be
too late those who can afford it are
getting ready for the smog season masks
and air filters have become hot items
I'm on like always and I'm already like
coughing so someone I can feel the
congestion here so I think it's better
to have one but that string goes on
you're around the years and I wear a
turban so that's not possible you know
yeah I'm a little worried because
they're quite warm looking you know like
it's like in this weather
wearing a mask doesn't reduce the
pollution but at least it gives people a
feeling they're doing something positive
for their health